thank you to manscaped and Shopify for
sponsoring the channel this week more on
them after the
[Music]
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it's me Tara Ericson alongside my dear
friend we've been watching all the saws
tell him your name my name is Aaron
mother freaking Alexander oh he added
him freaking in the
middle he is so ready to SL it down and
so am I so don't forget to leave a like
got to leave a comment and ring the
bell ring the bell yes that was great
also thanks prep for helping us edit
down these videos also if you want us to
call you super sexy get in the sexy game
you got to get on patreon okay you can
watch and sync up with the entire copy
watch all night with me and Aaron you
know what I'm saying also Greg and John
offer exclusive highlights and watch
alongs over there on the patre so if you
know what's good for you you know get it
get with it also follow us on social
media I'm I'm at Tara Ericson and Aaron
tellum I'm at the real Aaron Alexander
oh yes get on top of it should we just
get into it I'm stoked let's get into
[Music]
it so this one actually came out in
2021 was like really yeah really
recently oh my gosh yeah yeah okay I did
not realize that that is very
recent
that okay okay
rude he's got my first
budy
stop you did not just go down there oh
oh this s duty cop has got some Style
yes looks like he on on a yacht a yacht
he's ready to rock Floridian too
yeah get your hands in the
air oh there
mother is that Billy look oh no it's not
the
[__] that was a real pig face that
didn't even look fake you guys yeah it
was hyper realistic right
there oh man oh no thank you with that
I'll stop moving around once again also
looks like a movie looks like a movie
yep very cinematic right off the top I
like these extreme closeups yep yep like
the clarity wa his tongue oh okay oh no
oh that's that's messed up
yo hello detective Boswick I want to
play a game the three train is arriving
in 2 minutes new voice I think it's a
woman you have taken the witness stand
many times and reloaded innocent people
with your lies putting them away in jail
today it is you who will be railroaded
tear from your mouth the tongue that has
so often been used to lie and to
deceive only your weight will reip away
your lying tongue sa live or die oh
that's so awful oh my God it's terrible
hanging by his tongue oh
that's
waa that's you can't break out of it
buddy come on
now it off it off just come on just jump
down and rip it off come on the Train's
going to hit you man it's going to it's
coming for you let's oh is so God this
is the
worst I don't want to see
it oh oh
God yeah I mean it's all too late you
got you did a double you did the tongue
thing and the train thing you could not
you lost two for one buddy God
why I don't want it gross
spiral from the book of Saw oh the book
special needs abuse special needs
thought you woke now I'm not woke but
you can't say handicapped you can't say
you got to say special needs I'm trying
to be
respectful what was the name of the girl
Jenny he did everything for Jenny this
mother did some
[__] who the is nicer than Forest gum
his best friend was a and a white boy
with no
legs and she still
wouldn't oh man we get I know we're
going to stand up special in this song
Rico just got off the elevator [__]
let's do
this for my different
music why we get
that okay very different vibe for a Saw
movie yeah
okay oh wa that is a load of cash I want
that coke oh and some COC oh dang some
coco
cabana I think this is the biggest star
we've had in a Saw movie so far yeah
absolutely oh nice okay a
Mustang
fancy love it got so close you oh you do
an undercover op you don't clear it
there's no coordination we are homicide
oh that crew killed four people last
week and we got and we could have got
more of them if my cover wasn't blown on
your own as usual no backup cuz there's
nobody on the force I
can you're going to learn to be a team
player you're getting a partner Genie s
shank do I look like a Jamaican
Nanny just because your dad was Chief
Marcus Banks doesn't mean you get out of
the [__] 12 years ago I turn in a dirty
cop I get a metal Fork I also got a
bullet and I got to look over my back
for the rest of my career shut
up oh damn Zeke I want you to me
detective in training William shank
Texas
Banks there's a lot more stars in this
like everyone I see works all a lot oh
yeah you recognize everybody yeah I
recognize I guess partner I can't
remember I've seen him before but I know
I've seen I can't remember either
but oh oh gross okay that hazed it was
was it a joke or was that real it was a
real real Mouse a real rat you don't
want to be my partner you don't know
that your dad's the reason for all of
this Sam Jackson Banks and shank some
homeless guy got hit by the three train
you're
up different music yet again hey hey hey
hey hey new Vibes he's got a Camaro and
I love it Banks and rout to that 10
the urban Saw
movie it is indeed I'm down for black
saw let's
go this is my wife Emma this is my son
Charlie cute enjoy it while it lasts
nothing happier than the wife of a new
detective nothing more Angry than that
same [__] 10 years later H I'm Hab
Italian trust me women do not like you
when you call what what you telling me
about women young mother
[__]
guessing you're divorced I'm going
through a divorce kind of like chemo
[__] sorry sorry for what we're cops
this is the life we choose highest
divorce rate highest rate when you decid
to become a cop you pretty much assured
yourself you were going to die alone I
thought dentists had the highest rate is
that true I think never heard that until
this moment we have to unpack that later
I don't know what that means for
dentists me neither you can get away
with a lot lot of [__] in the daytime
that's right you could ride a lot of
before
dusk Pilates doesn't even exist Emma
loves Pilates I'm sure she does I'm sure
she does but don't worry about it you're
going to be fun I love this long
tracking shot that's great I love that I
hope there's more of those Chris Rock
doing rocking it he's rocking it is
rocking
it damn uh oh
yeah this bum's going to be tough to ID
I'm not too sure this is a bum I don't
know a lot of bums trying to get their
steps in yeah why do they automatically
assume a homeless guy right
rude maybe because they assume like no
standard citizen is just going to walk
down there like how would they even cuz
it's gross gu what is it there's enough
homeless people get hit by trains for
them to assume that that's the automatic
I guess or they live down there right oh
care Fair still rude still rude this
package just came in for me ass his
partner's from Yellowstone you guys can
tell us I think I feel like that was an
assumption made to make our main
characters look
smarter play
me oh we're moving into the USB stage of
s yes throwbacks hello detective Banks
one officer from your station refused to
be reformed he will not be the last to
play my game jigsaw I thought the jigsaw
killer was dead yeah but if it's another
copycat I recognize that
building what are you guys doing here oh
we thought your boys might need some
backup you Fitz it's not your case yo
Z if him and that girl have something to
do with it the pickups on their faces
are giving it away right here at the top
I'm talking about that girl that girl
and that guy had weird pickups like
they've yeah we'll just see if they are
involved I'm going to be like oh they
were giving slight details away in their
pickup shots is that a Tong feels like
gross 453 who's 453 dental records
confirm its Buzz someone needs to call
Cara his wife let her I already called
her do you know Cara no do they have a
dead husband emoji talk to her [__]
we had to notify her before it lead to
the Press me and The Rook were first on
scene isn't this protocol now you're
part of the team again Zeke oh that's
the reason for the weird pickups okay
drama when all you mother would treat me
like [__] shoot me in my back BOS was my
friend you realize your friend was gone
I get why you want this BOS was my
friend too but you can't do this alone I
need the whole department on this
working together B is my family man you
got to let me take lead you got to let
me catch this
mother that's was funny it's weird cuz
they want him to be funny but they also
trying to make him serious at the same
time right strange Choice banks is
taking Le I know some of you guys think
I'm a rat some of you think I'm a snitch
some of you are mad I your
mother B was last scen at Stewart's
point so there should be plenty of
surveillance footage check your hashtags
hey so what did he know cuz he was
chasing someone we need to focus on the
case and solve this so get the footage
to detective Banks and put your personal
[__] aside Brian you good no problem
here Captain who do they rat out like
why do they hate him so much like he
must have like really effed up pissed
off the whole department it's okay we
haven't did this I'm going to find
understand how did it happen Cara your
mother's on the phone
Lisa
history here no my sister's watching him
Ronda gets to see my son but I don't are
we really getting into this here not
today hey I'm William partner
Yep this is like strug damn say this is
uh structured differently this is like a
cop drama with a saw mystery exactly we
we have not hit a game cuz normally like
a saw thing going on while there's a cop
story going on right and we're just
solidly following this did B say
anything or act stressed out there was
one thing there was a black SUV parked
outside one night last week and he
walked up and I don't know the next
thing I know he was yelling at somebody
inside any idea what you were yelling
about if I see it again I'll get a
license
plate oh Dad you pull a gun on your old
man huh I could have killed you what are
you talking about I got the gun I could
have killed
you
jigsaw copycat that could be difficult l
a responsibility you got a problem with
that or you just scared I'm going to
embarrass you this ain't about you
that's the [__] that ruined your career
and your marriage we live in the same
building I saw you out front the other
day you nodded at me like we the only
two black guys in the
mall we haven't had a meal together in
over a year are you hungry you want to
go get a
slice
I'm going go to caras pay my respects
just come over tonight I'll order some
food we'll go over the case I got this
dad who need
you man family of cool cars huh right
they got style man she got mad whips
left and right 12 years ago I turned in
a dirty
cop hey what happened what happened he
pulled a gun on me the witness pulled a
gun on you wow they really turned their
back at them that hard even though that
cop accidentally killed a witness I
think killed cuz they're like he turned
his back on their own oh got it cuz I
thought maybe he just was like his
friend was also dirty which is why the
jigsaw copycat killed them John kber now
we're connecting the dots well why don't
you check with digital forensics and see
if anybody in B's phone log has a black
SUV phone's dead you got a charger let
me buy your phone shut up okay
don't drain my battery Watching
Twilight even though this is shot more
cinematically it is moving like a TV
episode and there is a lot of TV actors
in This besides Chris and besides
obviously Samuel the other ones I feel
like they're from cop dramas yeah it's
plotted like a cop drama yes yes like
this would be 45 minutes and then we
have to get to the next episode right
right not bad just different different
pacing than the other ones it's
different pacing but we also had the
traps to like counterbalance some of
that yes cop drama
right who's that he's chasing I know
that guy Benny Ry he's a hustler flops
in a burnt out bread factory down on
12th okay deals with a pusher street
named speed I'll take the building you
track down speed let me see that gun
over there the one on the left on behalf
of the Metro Police I want to thank you
for generosity this guy's an [__] why
suck I hate him I got [__] to do I'm out
what's his deal he's a crooked piece of
[__] they all are call it a night you
sure I think the way this is going our
uh our jigsaw Copycat has to be in the
force has to be I'm going to throw a
hell Mary I'm going to say it's the
chief love that the wman yeah yeah good
work
today or him yeah cuz he he was the only
one that seemed chill and like whatever
so I was like oh if they're trying to do
a trying to throw us off the scent yeah
the I think the the trophy reversal is
like the guy who's the closest to the
main character he's going to learn to
trust him of the course of the story
when he's actually the guy who's behind
it all then again what if what if it's
his
dad oh you you think Sam Jackson could
be behind it no but like maybe I don't
know this movie gets me I'm like they're
all it all the saws make me think every
each and everyone each and every person
is a new jig before until we get to the
end
wake up
Benny is that a dead
persons oh it's a fake person you all
right everybody's wearing these like are
you fake or are you dead yacht
hats
Fedora I don't like that you're
dead oo oh you're fake St leave me a
message gross call
me hello
[Music]
yeah they're trying to frame it like a
traditional serial killer kind of like
what's going on kind of thing oh boy
about to get a trap though okay here we
go let's get into the games there's been
people yelling in the audience like
where's the game right throwing popcorn
at the screen
oh ooh oh and a finger trap I don't want
I don't like
it so I'm to guess he's not part of it
[Music]
right he's not in on it he's not it w
what an interesting trap he is an
[__] he is and he is dirty so we know
we now know why it's happening he's
dirty but now he's in the water about to
get clean hello detective Fitch I want
to play a
game I want to play a game we're not
going to watch him play what are you
doing up I told you to take the rest of
the night off uh it's fine Charlie's
sleeping was sleeping just waiting for
him to get home she's having a girl's
night you better be careful with that
it's his
wife well I'm looking through all the
Metro records like you asked and BOS was
accused of lying on the stand more than
anybody that's why the tongue was at the
courthouse can I help you terone are you
Marcus Banks you know that place yeah
that's in La no I'm his son delivery
good yeah okay good pasta all right
pasta
dad uhoh dad's at the warehouse killing
that cop you don't like if I'm right
which I could be totally wrong what are
you doing okay what's going on here
Dad where he mother how the did you not
call me first I tried but you didn't
answer that goatee though yep cuz you
would have talked me out of it I told
the truth get the out of my face Z knew
I should have never let him become a cop
he turned in a dirty cop Pete was a
scumbag and what about the other cops WF
Action News here are you
in God damn all right sorry but I think
your face was trespassing on my property
is there something I can help you
with no no [__] you very
much they're believable father and son I
don't think I've ever seen them in a
movie together before no I haven't
either H thanks incoming hold my desk
Courier brought it we're holding him for
questioning it's weird to me he use the
tissue to open the box and need didn't
have gloves on when he touched the
actual thing just have to say that out
loud hello detective Banks salvation was
offered but it was declined with the
police department 12 Street bridge I
know that place until you come clean
many more will die I take it back it's
not the cop
[Music]
[Applause]
lady guys I might have been wrong there
might be a transan not a Camaro so just
before you get in the comments and get
crazy crazy I got one one guess
right damn oh is that a real one yep
real pigly this one's really into the
pig Motif they're leaning in
hard and these Tiffany boxes now we
think this copy cat's working
alone
fies yes or I don't know yet 982 Fitch
this is detective Bank requesting
backup it has to be his dad I mean
there's like so much that like people
met I mean it doesn't have to be I don't
know
if it is his dad I feel like his dad has
a partner in it yeah and he's like he's
helping take vengeance upon what's
happened
to I guess his clearly this is a
personal story like someone who has a
vendetta against the police department
yes my son called for backup three times
in 8 minutes to none of you mother you
get here I'm going to call dispatch and
find out when I do I'm going to take
this gun and shoot that mother
[__] it was
you damn you son damn Samuel Jackson
doesn't give a f
dude I don't think Samuel
Jackson too heavy
handed I know now it's like if it is
it's way too it's lay down too thick so
there's got to be a switch Yeah like
right there it can't be feel just like
beat him with a door or shoot him I
he's not going
to yeah you're right in 90 seconds the
water will rise to the height of the
copper wires you will be electrocuted
you murdered a man because he insulted
you put your hands I can see the
mother
wow survival is simple but it comes with
a sacrifice oh pull off your fingers the
device in your mouth which will start
the motor that will RI your fingers away
leaving you free to escape with your
life live or die make your choice let
the game
begin I kind of like that he just bit
down and there wasn't a lot a lot of
times with the people they're like what
do I
do he just like got to it yeah he
accepted it pretty
quickly yikes that is
rough oh my God no ah it makes me feel
[Music]
things no oh bite down bite
down oh God
youself see a
TI oh this effects have gotten
better
this is so rough
uh nope I think
he's oh my God oh my God wasn't fast
enough you weren't fast enough anything
special about the bridge where we found
the fingers it was where he shot that
kid this guy Benny writes who PA was
last seen with on July 4th we took it
off a pawn shop feed in Stewart point
and you didn't tell me I don't tell him
anything and this is where Benny gets
his meth this is some new ja City [__]
get the out of here come back when you
get some money I got some money hold up
a second hold up for a second all right
all right sit it down
baby got 10s
come is that a
bomb
Oh
rough oo damn no thank
you back inside get back inside whoa
so red in
there oh waa damn yeah
okay no way they didn't get
hit all
right
o you seen this man before I tell [__]
why cuz you're worried about that bone
sticking out your
leg oo a everybody knows that mother
Benny Ritz when was the last time you
saw him I've seen a [__] in two days
man the
street oh we know Benny's dead I want
Chinese food yeah it sounds good yeah
what do you like to get fried rice fried
rice I'm a combination fried rice kind
of guy shrimp fried rice if I had one
though yeah oh yeah the hell is this guy
ex cop partner snitched on him had to do
n years hard time system spit them out
so far this movie is largely
disconnected from all the other Saw
movies absolutely and way slower
yeah how you doing Pete 18 months sober
living in a church basement who could
ask for anything more detor shank
working kiss together I never thought
I'd say this but we need more saw in our
Saw movies
yeah and you saw it I mean with your own
eyes he's had his foot on the neck of
this community for way too long I'll
testify off St leave
you that's rough right I was mad for a
long time but now I take responsibility
I should have never pulled the trigger
only got nine years for that yeah that's
a low amount of time we were out of
control cops were giving their own
discretion to crack down on crime got 9
years for murder yeah straight up like
point blank what the hell you shot an
innocent guy but you turned on him
there's a code and you better learn how
to follow it or you're going to spend
the rest of your life watching your back
maybe it's a good thing they made as
partners I feel like it's him yeah it's
like giving off a Vibe right cuz we
don't know much about him but he's he's
here taking in all the information I
like someone cared about him died and
that's why he's doing this yeah he's
passing it what I'm like is he passing
info to his dad or did his dad go in
that warehouse and then the saw person
took his dad cuz his like his dad stand
that's so missing maybe right like why
did we see that pickup of the dad at the
warehouse that I'm like Shaq it's 9:00
a.m. what give me a call so I got to go
back to okay
hey what's going on what's going on
hands up
up this the delivery guy get him out of
here
the no way Zeke that one is not the same
I'm calling the bomb squad yeah I was
like we got two Dead Cops there's no
time get everybody out everybody out
everybody out is it beeping no but like
I would assume the same thing I'm like
protocol would be like get the bomb
squad right like screw protocol I guess
[Music]
oh oh it's got the SI size
yeah ew God that little puppet am I
getting under your skin detective
Banks oh it's this kid my wife Emma is
my son Charlie oh oh oh his partner got
kidnapped shoot Captain there's
something under here play me
so it can't be his dad if his dad is
like I had that wrong Constantine
paints maybe this is a misdirection yeah
I trust nothing me
[Laughter]
neither oh oh there it is got skins M
we're analyzing the tape recording hello
detective sh I want to play a game you
were head of your class at the police
academy he was obviously skinned there's
no game there doesn't make sense D's
reason I want to do this in the first
place he's working with the
dad it's a good thing they made as
partn the def cap don't believe it not
for a second you think he's really dead
no I feel like because just only that
part right cuz right cuz here's the
thing how would the killer know that if
it wasn't the partner how how would he
know about the tattoo or that he
informed him about the tattoo cuz he's
talked to him about the Sun how would
someone outside of their Dynamic know
that because he's new so I feel like
then the killer probably sent him in
sent Charlie in already at the top
because I think Charlie's the detective
son yeah yeah cuz that's why you got a
tattooed on him
yes hey O Brien yeah boss you seen
Zeke no not for a while oh yes I knew
that cuz he was my son is Charlie I
meant like the killer probably I was
calling the guy the guy Charlie I forget
his name the rookie cup the rookie I
feel like the killer sent the sent the
rookie in from the top maybe I don't
know my theory is that the rookie and
his dad are working are working together
somehow I I agree with you but also
trust no
one some guy in a pig mask he runs up on
me with a knife he just wanted to mess
with the cops careful while you're
looking for more more bodies to drop
I'll take your head and you to head of
an department now what did she do yeah
what what was that I must have missed
something here what is she guilty for
yeah killing the the rookie is such a a
lame misdirection because it doesn't
make sense with the theme of trying to
replicate the jigaw killer
right oh he's coming for her so they're
just taking out all the fu fu R Ro I
want to play again again game hey hey
it's hilarious that she already saw the
pig okay I was like and she hasn't shot
yet yeah come on now it's probably fake
right it's maybe it's yeah cuz it didn't
move at all it looked like it was on
something oh well the okay so you were
wearing a gas mask under there right
otherwise that don't make sense don't
make no dang sense garon in a few
seconds boiling hot wax will be coming
out of the pipe above you the only way
to stop yourself from being suffocated
is to sever your spinal cord with the
blade beneath your
neck that's so messed
up oh God that awful that's the
worst what a shitty parking job yeah
right
oh God no no just end it all I don't
want it I hate it I really don't want it
killer has edgy look I guess you didn't
hear the killer just attacked a cop at
third and beam it that was just a
diversion to get us out of the prein
she's down in the
basement oh God this is terrible no I
hate it I hate it all just H wax God
just put your neck down end it just end
it
open
it ah yeah she gone she's
dead oh no please don't I don't want to
see it I don't want to see
it oh God wo that's like gross I need
all the footage from the camera
in the evidence room still have mixed
feelings about um Chris Rock as the lead
though about the what about him as the
lead yeah me too look on the first frame
the safe door is open but on the next
it's shut there's 13 minutes missing I
can't tell you who deleted the video but
I can access who logged into the server
over the past day who's badge number 213
it's your partner done liy he shouldn't
have access how long has it been since
he was even on the job your father had
access to the location of shank's body
you said it was where your father took
you as a kid when was the last time you
saw your your father he's been missing
for a
[Music]
week now he's just we're at the Crux of
the movie where he just Parks diagonally
in every frame doesn't doesn't care
anymore no he's losing it losing his
marbles leave a message Dad why have you
not told anybody your dad's missing
that's my question amongst all of this
going on right and why does yeah
okay all right we're getting somewhere
let's get
it oh there's his dad finally
he okay so his dad's going to find
him so either his dad figured it out and
then got kidnapped I think figured it
out because remember he's like come over
for dinner we'll talk about the case and
I thought that was like a throwaway but
obviously Maybe he meant that and he did
the work quickly and figured it out I I
can see that yeah I don't I definitely
don't believe that he's a part of it
anymore right oh he knew the chief would
figure it out okay you want to play
games mother wait is
his got to get that mother
in that little Pig doll is the
worst
yeah felt that coming duh what yeah
right oh they're both going to be
kidnapped together Father and Son style
the third act reveal where we get our
crazy plan veiled to us see here oh
there's
Dad come on detective with the
mislead there's the saw music finally
yeah
back to being chained up on a pipe mhm
like the first one okay oh my God unlike
the first one okay so taking it back to
the Vintage are you going to sew off S
off your hand saw off your hand saw off
your
hand oh it's not going to work you're
going to break the we we've learned this
like from 10 years ago
man
oh nice who's hidden under there to like
undo the handcuffs definitely planted
there cuz why would a bobby pin just be
there he wants you to get
away
really
wow
partner oh no Pete is Pete his old
partner oh yeah yeah yeah right when you
Peter D leby murdered an innocent man
your career was shattered like blast can
you stand on the sidelines while Justice
is finally served let the games
begin oh he's going to get like fried to
death we're stretched to death like is
this like oh oh hit with glass oh snap
and it's going to come flying out at him
mhm give me the out of
his don't do it
oh h no get out of
there
oh wow that's
intense oh that was a Big Slice you
didn't even give him like 5 Seconds man
nope get me out come on
ass it's weird he didn't give him like
rules he was just like you can save him
or let him die let him die but there
wasn't any rules to the game
like oh God this guy's going to bleed
out he's got to be a gonner cuz yeah
this is his game not his game and throw
away the
K oh throw away
trash get it get it get it I'm sorry
it's not funny his facial expressions
were making me
laugh here we go we got some ass in his
head he's gone
dude H 100% dead dang that that yeah
he's going to get done and that guy's
going to bleed out
bye-bye come
on he's all glassed up which means he's
glazed over was he an alcohol anonymous
yeah well the partner was but I don't
know if banks was right that's where the
church he met him at the church the guy
who yeah yeah Banks isn't in AA you're
saying the guy that just died yes yeah
he ran the AA yeah yeah that death was
probably a little ironic he used to hit
the bot Bott hit yeah hitting that
bottle a little too hard except he was
sober so it's cruel but he was cruel
first yeah I mean that guy got away he
murdered someone and only did nine years
which is insane
yeah called it called it called it hi
buddy too obvious yeah I called that
[__] early
too no
[__] I've been loyal to you since the
first day we
met 15 years ago oh the day your partner
killed my father I knew it was I knew
they were yeah yeah you were like it's
just son I said brother but yeah oh my
God bro totally get out of here
well especially with the arm thing with
the arm it was so obvious that was a
little too heavy-handed cuz there's no
game involved it was just like a m was
just here you go
yeah Pete killed Charlie Emerson what
you thought I'd use my real name what
about your family what what about your
son fake fake fake I don't have a son
Charlie's sleeping was sleeping nice I
tattooed my dad's name in his arm ah
what a is my father I didn't even ask
him to come down here you did let me buy
your phone shut up
okay oh I deleted it there's no text
thread prior to that right the first
time you ever texted your
dad it's not good continuity wait he
never tried to call his dad this entire
time cuz if he blocked him on his own
phone wouldn't he correct and he would
not be able to get through and he did
try to call his dad but if he looked at
his phone wouldn't he be able to see
that it was blocked correct it would not
spiral symbol of change let's face it
these cops they're not going to clean up
on their own but we take tongue here few
bones there but come around let's do it
I want to trust you but I
can't
oh oh God article 8 was one of the most
corrupt police policies in history and
guess it was your dad's right-hand man
sorry should I say woman the whole time
time we'll handle it we always do huh
you watch my father die and I'm trying
to save yours if we're going to trust
each
[Music]
other thanes damn they said an alibi
Homie we going e someone up here to stop
don't come in don't come
in why don't come in oh cuz that'll trip
off okay got it your dad's the reason
for all of this this he's why I want to
do this in the first place dreaming
about this since I was 12 years
old it seemed pretty obvious that it was
[Music]
him what
the
what he just what he goes in the
elevator and goes away with the whole
Calvary in the
room what you guys
what he just is there and says like they
don't he's literally right there and
there's 35 people in the room it's a
secret okay Mary balls Miss reject
Nation you know what the funny thing is
I already owned this product before
agreeing to do this partnership I could
have used my influenc ring to get it for
free or at a discount but hey now you
can get it at a discount cuz this week
we are of course sponsored by manscape
as a married man who's always on the
move I value looking sharp while keeping
things efficient that's where manscapes
performance package 5.0 Ultra comes in
featuring the lawn mower 5.0 and it is a
game changer the package is honestly a
perfect gift for yourself or for another
man that you might know I'll give this
to John if anyone ask I pay for it out
of my own pocket but no seriously this
is easily the best because it comes with
not one but two NextGen blade heads see
the difference it's good think I have
two now for demonstration purposes so
you got the standard trimmer for a
perfect neat trim but this one the new
foil blade for that super smooth finish
and oh yeah it's all about safe grouping
with their Advanced Skin safe technology
plus they're waterproof so no more
crumbs on the carpet the package also
incles the weed whacker 2.0 for ear and
nose and I definitely use this because
look at me I'm a hairy guy and the must
have liquid formations the crop Soo
their aftershave lotion and the crop
preserver ball deodorant say goodbye to
post shave irritation and hello fresh
and the ultimate cherry on top two free
gifts manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and
the shed 2.0 toiletry rag again I
already have one the boxers I'm wearing
my here right now and the bag is perfect
for all your grooming Essentials as you
can see so you ready to elevate your
grooming game head to manscape.com and
use code reject for a cool 20% off plus
free shipping remember it's reject for
20% off at manscape.com let's get those
jingle balls holiday ready with manscape
thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
which is what we use for our merch store
and is our gamechanging partner in
eCommerce so whether you're launching a
passion project or scaling to new
heights Shopify is e-commerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating
your first online store to opening
physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI to that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on our journey
using Shopify for www.re nation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
there a war-winning support always there
to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all overc case shopify.com rejects start
your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team what
like they recognize him that he's on the
force no they didn't this is like the
SWAT team coming in and he had civilian
clothes on all right listen I get upset
y'all I get upset why he said like that
like they couldn't
see okay
new music new music at the end here
music new music new music at the end
here hey I like the music I didn't like
the movie but I like the
music oh man take it away man this was
disappointing I think it's disappointing
because well for a few
reasons one being there weren't a lot of
saw in our Saw movies there wasn't a lot
of traps though will say the traps that
we did have the were brutal they're cool
kind of different in a sense to the way
that Jon and the other uh jigsaws would
do it they seemed like more contained
which I thought was an interesting
choice was a little different except for
this last one was a little bit more
extravagant kind of what we become
accustomed to in the later Saw movies
but I think for the most part and I
don't I feel like you kind of expressed
a similar sentiment as we're watching it
it was kind of slow uh and kind of I
don't know it didn't have that same sort
of intrigue or same sort of thing that
captured your attention because when you
come into a Saw movie at least as we've
experienced you come to expect certain
things to happen it starts with the
initial opening uh game and then it goes
into what who's actually doing this
while the there's players learning a
lesson while they're playing a game in
addition to the cops trying to figure
out what's going on as the games are
happening and I feel like without that
active element of what's going on on
this side of things it kind
ofat of yeah it drags it kind of creates
a sense of this uh not having this
balance not having this harmony that
we've come to uh know over the course of
these games also I felt
like listen I like Chris Rock I think
he's a funny dude and I've seen sgo
Fargo season 4 he's great in that like
he can really do this dramatic stuff if
he really wanted to I think just the way
I don't know if it was the writing or
the directing but I feel like there's a
lot
of things they wanted him to do but that
didn't mesh well like the first third of
the movie he was just like Chris Rock
the comedian you know had like a whole
bunch of bits okay he's like he's this
funny dude but he also has this moral
code but he also is just very angry and
just like it just didn't mesh well and I
felt there points were like we really
want you to take Chris Rock seriously
and I'm like no I can't because I just
don't believe it and I thought the
Killer was really obvious for like most
of the movie I know I was making a lot
of guesses here and there but I feel
like I was defini definitively locked in
when they tried to do the misdirection
of he had his body skinned alive because
one we've come accustomed to the fact
that with these games there has to be
some sort of lesson that the person
who's being put into the games or being
murdered is learning but with that one
in particular there was no game it was
just death and that doesn't track with
the rest of what's going on and maybe
that's just me as an audience member
who's consumed these movies but I feel
like with the people within this world
if you know that this is a saw ripoff or
you know this is a jigsaw ripoff you
should know or maybe I would think to I
don't know study the behavior of Jigsaw
or like read the books or something
because if you know
that there there's there's the sense of
there's this Motif or there's this this
thematic thing that he's trying to
achieve within those those uh those
games right so it just doesn't really
track
well yeah also I it was shot well I I'll
give I'll give it that the movie was
shot very well but yeah it was it was
kind of a disappointing thing for me
also in the Tiffany boxes we saw the
kills happened on camera and then a
slice of that Tiffany box body part
being presented on camera the one part
we didn't get was the Charlie skin which
was like what he was saying like we
normally see a game and a lesson learned
and that that's like as soon as that
popped up it was like wait what we
haven't we didn't see this uh which made
it a little more obvious I think um they
tried to set up some of the the glances
and the looks around at the top I think
they were like trying to throw us off
the scent I'm not sure who directed this
or if they directed um some other ones
but I do agree that in the beginning it
was a little slow it it did feel like a
cop drama in the beginning it kind of
picked up pace once we got to a game
which was exciting sometimes even with
the saw stuff I'm like cool let's slow
down on the gang uh the game aspect and
let's get into the stories of the people
playing it which I really enjoy which
feeds off on the games a lot better and
this one was I don't know if like when
it would get to the game it was pretty
quick and the buildup just seemed from
the top obviously has to be a cop inside
there has to be a mole cuz we're just
dealing with all these cops and and
dealing with the backstory of like uh
Chris Rock's character being giving away
a cop and his dad being the captain and
then him and the new Chief being like
we'll take care of it it just seemed um
to not even Veer away from that even a
little bit which is why I think it felt
slow in the beginning because we we were
like oh we're setting the foundation
this is the foundation we know where
we're going we're not going outside of
it we're not even going to take a guess
as to like could it be wait could it
we've I mean you kind of felt that way
within the characters that we that we
saw but it was all you knew that it was
going to be a cop like a cop that was
closed to him and I think that's the
problem that we never thought that it
could be someone outside of of his life
or um a cop that maybe it's a cop's wife
or I don't know anyone else in the
outside world it was all internal which
is fine I just uh I I don't know I the
you guys know I think the last one I got
really upset when the guy sets down the
the uh you know the the mask as though
he's been there because he sets down the
mask from one and he sets it down as
though that guy has been there the
entire time endings when it's like that
I get upset and that's the thing that I
remember this one what I'm going to
remember is that 35 SWAT team members
came in and that guy in the elevator
going down with a gate closing the swats
not going to be like hold that elevator
who the f is this guy and that guy's
going to get away and just say sh this
is not okay with me this is not okay
with me it's endings like that that I
just go come on guys we have to give our
audience something more of like I don't
know a little more Intrigue I some
respect you know she is smart come on I
did think though that the Samuel Jackson
being up on the on the puppet strings
and then putting his arm up with a gun
and then him being shot I thought that
was great that's a great game a great
setup I loved like that moment I loved I
was like wow that's a very smart thing I
wish that it was just set up a lot
better to for that like payoff to really
to really like hurt or guttery hurt us
and then also be more of a surprise as
to who was setting it up that was the
only clever thing in the movie I agree
that what that really was like we didn't
get we still have not in these last ones
gotten the switch where we went
oh and we got that for a little while in
the beginning the first few yeah we have
not gotten that since and that is that
is upsetting to us because we've we've
watched these back toback which most
people haven't we're going through them
um and I hope that Ted which we're going
to watch has some bait and switches or
some surprises for us that were not
absolutely able to to call it um in the
beginning I mean you called it earlier
than me but like when you asked him
about the arm I was like this is weird
is he's he's not dead like that's he
just he just it's like a little piece of
skin he put there right like this is a
setup and that was yeah I I make sense
yeah it didn't make sense yeah I think
these last two
were they were both of them were were
kind of disappointing um I think this
one was more boring than it was boring
and bu boring it was I'm sorry it was uh
boring in addition to being
disappointing and yeah I think the the
last movie had better traps that was
like very cool and I feel like it was
the Trap aspect of things kind of
hearkened back to those earlier movies
which I did appreciate yeah but this one
the the traps are cool very few of them
and I feel like the closest things we
got to sort
of the like for example when he had to
save or like he was put to the test of
saving his old part partner that felt
like something more akin to like the
earlier Saw movies like having our lead
go through like a journey or a gauntlet
of experiences to teach them a lesson
but yeah it just didn't utilize the
games well and this movie was largely
removed from all of the saw stuff from
the original cuz at least there's like
some sement of connection but just like
oh yeah I kind of know that guy and I
like what he was about so I'm going to
do the thing that he was doing
but yeah but there's not as much
Intrigue because it's all very much
inhouse and there's certain things that
we did that and I correct me if I'm
wrong maybe you have a better memory on
this aspect of things than me what was
the whole point of going to his ex-wife
and talking about the kid and whatnot do
you
remember there was no point except to go
and talk to the wife to tell him that
his part that the partner was dead and
to established that he had a kid that we
never saw never came back back up I was
trying to as I was speaking it out I was
like maybe I'll find a loop around it
never came back around they didn't I
thought that they were going to use his
son as a ploy but they only used his dad
so they didn't bring it back around but
to your point like with the games um I I
don't remember which one this is from
but remember there's a old woman and a
guy tied together and I think that guy
did some [__] like she there was some
weird stuff but when we saw that game
and they were not leads they're just
just a game in a part of that movie and
I don't remember the number but I
seriously felt for that woman and was
like yeah let that guy die because I
think he did some crazy ass [__] and she
just happen that one was four and she
okay and she just had but I that game
just popped my head because I was like
they weren't even Le it was just a game
that we saw that I but I really felt for
both of the characters because of the
setup and the foundation these ones
moved a little bit fast and for some it
like during the game I was like I don't
know if I care as much that it's I
already know that it's going to be all
cops who are dying and it all just seems
to be cuz they're dirty versus the other
ones there was a little bit like he did
some [__] he he was touching people you
shouldn't have and you know that you
just go oh yeah I can't wait to see you
die and these ones were just like yeah
great you're a dick and do deserve to
die like You're a murderer basically in
in sheep's in cop sheep's clothing um
yeah because this more felt like revenge
in the other traps at least when when
John was doing it his more his thing was
about to teach a lesson yeah it was like
a a violent ordeal to give somebody a
chance of redemption in his eyes and
they were there was none of that they
were just skipping right to it now I've
kind of got it they're just skipping
right to it of going and now the lesson
you need to learn is cuz you shot
someone and you must pull your fingers
off or fall back and you'll be
electrocuted and you're like but what is
the lesson that he's learning in between
pulling off of his fingers and being
electrocuted we didn't get any of those
cops saying anything seeing anything
feeling anything extra for them except
the Little Foundation that we set up
that's it's like you're a dirty cop
which gets old after a second yeah the
thing about yeah this one didn't feel
like a Saw movie it felt like a dirty
cop movie with the motif of the saw sort
of theme to it mhm you know cuz yeah
exactly yeah cuz it was just like okay
let's take this story okay what's the
thing that gets people intrigued with
this kind of story of uh the the because
we've seen stories like this before in
movies you know the the entire uh
Precinct is is uh dirty except for the
main cop so like okay what's the thing
to make people interested in going to
see this movie okay we we'll make it a
saw copycat and but they they did a saw
copycat without doing any of the things
that make saw saw that makes saw
interesting that makes saw not not
divisive but like I don't there's like a
code to what he's trying to do and they
like because it's a copycat they sort of
Miss the the point of it I guess I don't
know they I think they miss a point too
the point because it's like they use the
same gum over and over for the same
people of like you're a dirty cop and
it's like well they've all they yeah
they killed innocent people like we get
it but there's something about it that I
we didn't feel it with them like and
there's other ones where you're sitting
there with that character who's about to
die and you're like can't wait till you
die yeah but like you really feel it in
these for some reason I was like oh I
felt the game the game is gross there's
people that you root for and there's
people that you hate and you can't wait
to die and with these these games you
felt none of that none none of it there
was no like push and pull of like who's
it going to be and why oh [__] why are
we here with this person right now or
why are we there and like who is setting
this up is it going to be revealed and
it just sort of fell felt like yeah well
I I guarantee you one of these people
we've seen on camera in the first 15
minutes is the person right it just felt
that's what it felt like it didn't keep
me in the beginning I was guessing a lot
right I took a lot of guesses like in
the first five minutes I was like
they're giving weird glances weird looks
and then after we went into it you kind
of go all right I see what we're doing
here exactly which yeah it's it's you
know it's disappointing uh let's hope
that 10 is is better and and more fun
and maybe puts in more of the saw games
I would give you know this
one probably a six um but yeah I mean I
just I wouldn't want
to I'm G to give it a six because I did
really like that Samuel Jackson the
puppet thing that was great I love that
and also you guys what is up with the
Easter egg puppet Pig thing in the
butcher shop was just sitting there and
no one noticed that except we did anyway
I'll give I'll give it a six and I hope
the next one's better also if you guys
are listening to this on Apple or
Spotify I'm supposed to say this like 30
hours ago give this a rating so if
you're listening to this as a pod Cassie
give us a rating please it super helps
us um and yeah you shout out your rating
Aaron let's do it you know I think the
thing that made me like the Saw movies
was the games and also the the the
Intrigue or like the the morality behind
it and I another thing that would
tribute to my rating would be the fact
that would I recommend this to people or
would I want to watch this again with
somebody that I know and I have no
desire to see this movie ever again uh
so I'm probably going to go with like a
5.5 yeah I no a five I'm Tak I'm taking
it to a five because it's not only not
connected to the other movies it just
doesn't have any of the pizzazz or the
Intrigue of those other movies so yeah
it's a five for me yeah I well let's
let's hope that it's better guys leave a
leave a like leave a comment tell us
what you thought um you know ring the
bell subscribe do all the things we love
you so much thank you for going on this
journey with us if this is your first
time listening or watching we've gone
through all of them we're at number nine
we've gone through one through nine and
we've got 10 left and we're doing it
soon so we'll we'll do through the whole
series get get on top of it join us uh
we love you so much and we will see you
on the next one
bye